fred anderson man this guy has been
really good of late you look at his last
two starts point 77 era and the way he's
getting it done is by filling up the
zone that's right anderson who rocks and
fires
and a base hit bunt opportunity opens
things up and a throw to first by
narvaez and what a way to start and we
already got some action going on if
kepler
i think wants to see whether or not this
is a foul ball or not so the umpires
getting together ron culpa the crew
chief he's behind the plate did it hit
between his legs
did it catch his leg or did it go in
between his legs take another look at it
from the side
did it get him
did he get him in the right leg and he
pushed it out he didn't play it off if
he did he kept running
it looked like he hit his calf and
knocked it fair so now the umpires no
signal yet craig council is going out to
ask a couple of questions of ron culpa
and to your point tim now the brewers
could come back and say well it hit him
when he was out of the batter's box
yeah great counselor just kind of
laughing about it and craig and ron
culpa are having a conversation about
great council we'll head back into the
dugout moving on forward yep slater
bounces onto short ureas at shortstop
today has it throws the first in time
so not a 2-3 put out but a easy change
in the scoreboard a 6-3 put out two
ounce bases empty darren ruff his first
at that
darren ruff blasts that one to left
field it is gone
giants on the board in the first inning
and darren ruff does it again he's had a
big impact himself on this giants team
the solo home run for darren ruff
one nothing giants in the first
stay hot darren ruff
fifth home run in his last 56 at bats
off a left-handed pitching and he got a
fast ball that he liked and delivered it
in the left field stands wow middle end
that was actually more center cut for
anderson tried to go in on him and
darren ruff barrels that right out of
the ballpark they're on the board early
today is a day for johnny cueto to give
the giants as much length in this start
as he possibly can colton wong brewers
are going to see a lot of different
stuff today that was a
different kind of hesitation move and he
totally froze colton wong
escobar that's a 2 48 24 homer 71 rb
guys
seven homers as a brewer 17 is a
diamondback they'll wind up in the 1-2
when escobar swings drives this one
toward left center and slater says i got
it as he moves to the right one two
three for milwaukee afternoon giants one
brewers nothing 20 pitches so far for
anderson solano double play ball rios to
law back to first
taylor made there's certain pitchers
that when they get a man on first they
don't really care they're going i'm
going to make a pitch and i'm going to
get two outside of this bad boy it's a
combio change up down
that's textbook double play he turns it
as good as anybody or as good as you can
there's two down and omar narvaez will
be the batter for the brewers
narvaez
deep right center
this one going
going and gone
the brewers have the lead at 2-1 on a
blast by narvaez first hit of the game
from milwaukee and it rides the jet
stream
that was marvelous slider
saw it
high enough for him to get to it
there's a no doubter there you almost
want to know who's going to hit that
car that's sitting on a pedestal
that makes that walk by yelich hard to
discount what he's been doing he's been
getting on base let the big guys come up
and drive you in top of the owner now in
austin slater
slater pops it up
colton wong back pedaling into shallow
center it's another three up and three
down inning for fred anderson he's
retired nine in a row brett anderson
coming up with a chance to move him
along and a throw to first and plato
throws it down the right field line
nobody was covering the bag
jackie bradley jr easily into second
base and some bad communication with the
giants one strike colton wong driving
that run
here comes jackie bradley jr and colton
wong delivers
another big two-out base hit
he hit that one just inside the line
third base side
and the brewers now lead three to one
colton wong with his 26th rbi wong's
been doing this all year willing to go
opposite field
great piece of hitting right there
scores a run another
two out base hit two out on the out
some bad news for the brewers as brett
anderson was
getting ready to take the mound in the
top of the sixth inning he's gonna have
to leave this game he has had some
really good appearances this year and
some long stretches and you can see he's
really favoring his lower half right
there
been on the injured list a couple of
different times this season he's dealt
with knee problems he takes a rest on
the bench and he's gonna be done in this
game after five
retire the last
nine batters he faced curtis is gonna
take over on the mound bullpen johnny on
the spot here in the sixth curtis is in
a pickle base has loaded nobody out
crawford has one hit and two at bats
today
one and one to count bryant at third
rough at second floor is it first
crawford drives that one out toward
right center field not that deep though
peterson underneath it makes the catch
tagging from third bryant he'll come in
to score and also tagging from second
very importantly darren ruff he goes to
third so crawford gets a sacrifice fly
the giants are down a run now and set up
to tie the game at least
a run-in for san francisco
the kick and the pitch hey struck him
out swinging
blue one by him on the outside corner
that's a big strikeout for him
fastball 94. that's a that's a bigger
pitch than he's thrown probably with
this brewers club that right there
chance to be one out away from getting
out of this jam you've got to play off
that aggression a long look now the
pitch
high fly left field yelich
drifting underneath of it and curtis
damage control indeed
gives up just the one unearned run they
head to the bottom of the sixth inning
all right new pitcher jose alvarez
guzuria's chance to atone for that error
in the top half of the inning
and it gets by the catcher here comes
escobar it's 4-2
that's why putting the ball in play and
having that runner at third base makes
such a difference you start going over
signs you try to get make things too
complicated sometimes you just
miss with a change up it's almost like
he didn't know if he
maybe got crossed up or if it was just
i don't know it's like he just missed
eyed it a run is in on what will be i
think a wild pitch now a man who homered
twice yesterday and if the omers here
would tie the game it's brandon bell to
pinch it
belt to center field with good carry out
there on its way
gone brandon belt
he's done it again
and tied the game four to four
and he delivers once again
ties this game up 4-4
stay hot brandon belt wow
13-game hitting streak that's a career
high for
number nine he gets a breaking ball out
of the plate that's the pitch that he's
been hammering soft stuff down in the
zone
and they continue to keep throwing it to
him
i thought bradley may have a chance to
get to this look how high he gets up
whoa just out of the outstretched glove
of bradley jr and they're grinded to try
to figure out what to throw the 11th
pitch of the at-bat here
and that one is right back up the middle
into center field base hit crawford
around third and he's gonna score the
giants are ahead five to four
what a tremendous at-bat from tommy la
stella even better than a walk
get a base hit rbi standing on first
base with nobody out on the 11th pitch
the giants win this game we're gonna
look back on that about as being the at
bat of the game for sure
[Music]
one out away
from a win here on sunday and a series
victory against the brewers
last chance for milwaukee is jackie
bradley jr 5-4 giants
that one topped on the ground lestella
throws to first in time and the giants
win the game and win the series and
somehow the giants found a way to come
from behind today they were down 4-2 and
they beat the brewers 5-4